in today's lesson we're going to mix
things up a bit
normally i give you a bunch of puzzles
to solve but today
i'm mostly just going to ask you to sit
back and relax while i tell you a story
i hope you'll find it an intriguing
story since it involves a very special
puzzle this puzzle has a name
it's called the hardest logic puzzle
ever
it's a fiendishly difficult variation on
the sort of question puzzles
we considered in our last lesson however
before i can tell you the story i need
to introduce you to a piece of logical
machinery we've not had an occasion
to discuss before so let's get that out
of the way right now
in lesson four we discuss logical
connectives
such as not and or
and if then let's recall specifically
what we said about
if then statements meaning statements
where we say if p
then q we decided that a statement of
this form
should be considered false when the
first part is true
and the second part is false we also
decided
that such statements should be
considered true in any other
circumstance
statements of the form if p then q are
typically referred to as
conditional statements or just
conditionals for short
now one thing about conditional
statements is that you cannot
generally switch the order in other
words the statement
if p then q is usually different
from the statement if q then p
for example the statement if spot is a
normal dog then spot has four legs
is true but if spot has four legs then
spot as a normal dog
is false but sometimes you want to say
not just if p then q but you also want
to say
if q then p we capture this idea
by using the if and only if connective
in other words if i say p
if and only if q you should take that to
mean the same thing
as if p then q and
if q then p you can think of this
assertion
as saying that p and q are logically
equivalent
they always have the same truth value
either both true or both false so the
statement
p if and only if q should be considered
true
when paq have the same truth value
either both true or both false
and false otherwise statements using
the if and only if connective are
referred to as
biconditional statements since they
really involve two separate conditional
statements
we're almost ready to begin but let me
make one final note
we call this the hardest logic puzzle
ever for a reason some of the details
will get pretty hairy later on
i promise that as we go along it will
not be necessary to work through
every detail of every scenario we'll
consider you'll be fully able to follow
the story
as long as you get the gist of what's
being claimed
that ends the setup time to get down to
business
are you comfortable is your popcorn
ready good
let's begin our story the hardest logic
puzzle ever
was introduced by philosopher george
bulos in a paper published in 1996
the paper was called the hardest logic
puzzle ever
the puzzle is this we are to imagine
three
gods the gods are named true false
and random true only makes true
statements
and false only makes false statements
but random is a wild card
each time he's asked a question he
mentally flips a coin
and depending on the result he decides
whether to answer the way true would
answer
or the way false would answer your task
is to determine which god is which by
asking no
more than three yes no questions
however there's another complication
though the gods
understand english perfectly they will
answer in their own language
in this language the words for yes and
no are da
and ja but you don't know which word
means yes and which word means no
so there you go you have three yes no
questions
but you don't know who you're speaking
to and you won't know what his answer
means
what can you do
let's clarify a few points before we
continue it's perfectly fine
to direct more than one question to the
same god
in other words it's not required that
you direct your questions to a different
god each time
also you don't have to have all three of
your questions worked out in advance
it's fine to ask a question and then to
let the answer to that question
determine your next question now like
all good stories
this one seems to have an innocent
beginning no doubt it's a difficult
puzzle
but we've seen difficult puzzles before
eventually we'll come to the solution
and then that will be the end of the
story right ha
let's have a look at bulow's solution
since his solution was very complex
he built up to it in stages specifically
he used some
gateway puzzles to build up to the main
event
here's the first of those puzzles
imagine that i place
two aces and a jack face down on the
table in a row
i know which card is which but you don't
your task
is to point to one of the three cards
and then to ask me a single yes no
question
i stipulate in advance that if you're
pointing to an ace
then i'll answer your question
truthfully but if you're pointing to the
jack
then i'll answer either yes or no
completely at random
what can you ask me so that based on my
answer
you'll be able to definitely identify
one of the cards
as an ace this puzzle has a similar
flavor to those from our last lesson
you might want to pause the video here
to use what you learned there
to work out this puzzle are you ready
for the solution
here we go one question that works
is to point to the middle card and to
then ask
is the left card an ace let's consider
the possibilities
suppose you're pointing at an ace then
according to the rules
i'll answer truthfully if i now say yes
then the left card is an ace and if i
say
no then the right card must be the
second ace
but suppose you're pointing at the jack
then i'll answer randomly
but that's okay since in this case the
left and right cards are both aces
so if i answer your question with yes
then you won't go wrong by assuming the
left card is an ace
and if i say no then you won't go wrong
assuming the right card is an ace
do you see the point regardless of what
you're pointing at
you can interpret yes to mean the left
card is an ace
and no to mean the right card is an ace
and i only ask you
to identify one card is an ace problem
solved
this shows how we can sometimes extract
useful information even when our
conversation partner
might be behaving randomly but now
things get more complex
here's bulows's second warm-up puzzle
essentially as he presented it
suppose that somehow you have learned
that
you are not speaking to random but
instead are
definitely speaking to true or false but
you don't know which
further assume that the god to whom
you're speaking has condescended to
speak in english
suppose you need to know whether or not
dushanbe
is in kargisia what one yes no question
can you ask
so that the response will definitively
resolve that issue
we'll come to the solution in a moment
but first let me clarify this business
about duchambe and kregizia
first kirgisia is the former name of the
small country today known as kyrgyzstan
dushanbe is actually the capital city of
the neighboring country of tajikistan
therefore dushanbe is not in kragisia
i deliberately left the puzzle
essentially as bulow stated it
as an illustration of the sense of humor
of some academics
as we'll see bulows is about to
establish the principle
that if we know we're not speaking to
random and if the gods answer in english
then we can ask a single question of the
gods
to determine whether or not any
particular factual assertion is true
a normal person might use something
simple like one plus one equals two
as an example of a very basic fact claim
but bulos instead amused himself
by picking something incredibly obscure
anyway if you want to take a shot at
this one then pause the video here
here's the solution we can ask the
question
are you true if and only if
dushanbe is increasing now
this question involves a biconditional
statement
its two parts are one we are speaking to
true
and two dushanbe is increasing
if these two statements have the same
truth value
both true or both false then the true
answer to the question is yes
and the false answer to the question is
no
now we already know that dushanbe is not
in kirgisia so item two is false
knowing that what will true say if we
ask him this question
well he'll reason that item one is true
in this case
and therefore that the truthful answer
is no and that's what he'll say
and if we address the question to false
well
he'll reason that item one is false and
therefore that the truthful answer is
yes
and he'll lie and say no in other words
regardless of whether we're speaking to
true or to false
the answer will be no but just for the
sake of argument
suppose it were actually true that
duchamp is in corgisia
in this case item 2 would be true how
would the gods respond
this time well
this time true would reason that both
items are true
meaning the truthful answer to the
question is yes and that's what he'll
say
but if we're talking to false then he'll
reason that item one is false
meaning the truthful answer to the
question is no
but then he'll lie and say yes so
regardless of whether
we're speaking to true or to false the
answer will be yes
which brings us to the best part suppose
we use x
to represent any factual assertion whose
truth value we wanted to know
and suppose that we know that we're not
speaking to random
then we ask are you true if and only if
x
if x is a true statement then both gods
will answer yes
if x is a false statement then both gods
will answer no
for example suppose we want to know if
the road we're driving on will take us
to the city
we could ask are you true if and only if
the road takes me to the city
a yes answer means it will take me to
the city while a no answer means it
won't
now i went through those possibilities
very carefully to illustrate the sort of
case-by-case analysis
that will become increasingly important
as we go along
however i think we'll quickly drive
ourselves crazy
if we constantly stop to analyze every
case for
every scenario we'll consider so for the
rest of the lesson
you're welcome to pause the video
periodically to work things out for
yourself
or you can simply take my word for a few
things as we go along
okay back to the story the principle
that we just discovered
that biconditional statements can be
used to get direct answers to direct
questions
so long as random is out of the picture
continues to work even if the gods
answer with da
and ja to see this suppose you're
definitely talking to true
and suppose x represents some factual
assertion whose truth value we wish to
know
we can ask does da mean yes if
and only if x it turns out
that an answer of da means that x is
true
and an answer of ja means that x is
false
now you'll need to consider four cases
to verify this the statement
x is either true or false and da either
means yes or no
the analysis of the cases proceeds in a
manner nearly identical to what we've
already seen
but let me repeat the main point when x
is true
the true god will answer da regardless
of whether da means yes or no
and when x is false he will answer ja
regardless of whether job means yes or
no we now have what we need to
understand bulow's solution
to the hardest logic puzzle ever
remember our challenge was to determine
which god was which
by asking no more than three yes no
questions
the true god only makes true statements
the false god only makes false
statements
and the random god sometimes answers
truthfully and sometimes answers falsely
but remember the gods will answer in a
language in which the words for yes and
no
are da and ja but you don't know which
word means yes and which word means no
now since bulow says opening question is
the most complex
and since the second and third questions
are simpler it will be convenient to
consider his questions in reverse
let's label the gods a b and c suppose
we've learned
b's identity and that we know that he's
not random
we can now ask him does da mean yes
if and only if a is random
if we know that b is true then we're in
precisely the situation we considered a
moment ago
where a is random is playing the role of
x
an answer of da now means that a really
is random
and an answer of jaw indicates that
actually c is random
if we know that b is false then the
logic will be reversed
but we'll still be able to identify
random and that will effectively solve
the problem
in this scenario we already know b's
identity
our question definitively identified
which of a and c is random
and then we'll know that the remaining
god is true
now we back up one step suppose we've
definitively identified b
as a non-random god but we don't yet
know whether he's true or false
we want to identify b definitively in
other words
is he true or is he false
we can use the solution of our second
puzzle to ask
does da mean yes if and only if one plus
one equals two
as we've seen since one plus one equals
two
is known to be true an answer of da
implies we're speaking to true while an
answer of ja
implies we're speaking to false
so all that's left is to find a first
question that definitively identifies
one god as not random it's actually this
step that causes most of the complexity
for this purpose bulos came up with this
we'll let x be the assertion you are
true
if and only if b is random and we now
ask
a does da mean yes if and only if x
in other words does dam mean yes if and
only if
you are true if and only if b is random
now if you care to work through the
logic
you'll find that there are many cases to
consider
a is either true false or random b
is either random or not random and da
means either yes or no
to simplify things for a moment let's
assume that a
is not random then the possible cases
are shown in this table
surveying the table it turns out that if
a
is not random then an answer of da means
that b
is random and answer of jaw means that b
is not
random either way we've identified
someone who is definitely not random
and if a is random well then we're right
back in the scenario
considered in our first puzzle even if a
is random we won't go wrong by
interpreting da to mean that c
isn't random and we won't go wrong
interpreting ja
to mean that b is not random okay
let's take it from the top bulow's
solution is to start by asking god
a does da mean yes if and only if you
are true if and only if b
is random the answer to this question
definitely identifies one of the gods is
not random
let's say b we then ask b does da
mean yes if and only if one plus one
equals two
this will tell us for certain whether b
is true or whether b
is false and then we ask b does da mean
yes if and only if a is random
and then we're done who you can see why
boolos called this the hardest logic
puzzle ever
while we've seen is all very ingenious
but it sure has an awful lot of hard
work
in fact it's so much hard work
that we might wonder if things are
really as bad as all that
do we really need these very intricate
nested
biconditional questions to get the job
done
this leads us to the next part of our
story in 2001
philosopher tim roberts pointed out that
a much simpler solution is possible
it turns out that we don't need bulows
as intricate questions after all
we can get by with just standard if then
statements
if you recall our discussion of the
heaven hell puzzle you'll recognize the
techniques roberts used
his solution uses the same strategy as
bulows
use the first question to identify one
of the gods as definitely not
random use the second question to
determine
which of true or false this god is and
then use the third question
to find the identities of the other two
gods
here's how he did it first we go to god
b
and we ask if i asked you if god a was
random
would you say da let's consider two
cases
just to see how the analysis goes
suppose
b is true let's also suppose that a
is random and that da means yes
with these assumptions if true is asked
if a is random then he'll reply with yes
and since da means yes true
will indeed reply with da when asked
whether a is random
so b's answer to the conditional
question is da
now continue to suppose that b is true
and a is random
but now assume that da means no again
true will answer yes when asked if a is
random that means saying
ja so b's answer to the conditional
question is no
since he will not say da when asked if a
is random
thus b will again say da in this
scenario
it can be difficult to keep track of all
the cases but if we suppose that b is
true
then the cases work out like this
the point is this if b is true
then a response of da tells us that a is
random
and a response of ja tells us that a is
not random
and if a isn't random then c is
incredibly
it turns out that this conclusion holds
even if b
is false that is a case-by-case analysis
shows that if b is not random
then a response of da implies that a is
random
and a response of jaw implies that c is
random
and if b is random then as before
we won't go wrong assuming that either a
or c is not random
and just like that we've succeeded in
our goal of finding a god who is
definitely not
random let's suppose that god is c
roberts now suggests asking c if i
asked you if you always told the truth
would you say da
this question will tell us whether or
not c is true
the possible cases are shown in this
table
a response of da means that c is true
and a response of ja
means that c is false the final question
is again directed at c
this time we ask if i asked you if b was
random
would you say da this will solve the
problem the possible cases are shown in
this table
now i remember one spending the better
part of an afternoon working through all
these cases
if you have the patience for it there's
something truly beautiful about how
everything works out just right
what matters for us though is that final
column
a response of da tells us that b is
random and a response of jaw tells us
that b
is not random it's like a magic trick
now as i've said it's not so important
to work through each and every case
what is important is that we've
dramatically simplified the solution
instead of using intricate biconditional
questions
it's sufficient to use normal
conditional questions instead
but perhaps we can simplify things still
further after all
robert's solution while simpler than
bulos's is still pretty complicated
it turns out that we can do much better
the saga continues
the next part of our story came in 2008
when philosophers brian rayburn and
landon rayburn
simplified things still further they
noticed something that had been missed
in prior solutions to the puzzle
we've been assuming that no useful
information
could be gleaned from speaking to random
since we've no idea how to interpret
anything he says
but this is not necessarily true for
example
suppose we go up to any god and ask have
you ever told a lie
true will truthfully say no and false
will lie and say no
but remember that random always answers
either as true would answer
or as false would answer in other words
he doesn't just
answer randomly saying yes or no as
though he hadn't even heard your
question
but rather decides randomly whether
he'll behave like true or like false
that means random will always answer no
to this question
this opens up the possibility of getting
direct answers to direct questions
even if we're talking to random and
rayburn and rayburn devised a way of
doing just that
their solution doesn't require wasting
the first question
on just finding one god who's definitely
not random
instead they suggest asking god a
if i ask you if you are true in your
current mental state
would you say job and it turns out that
regardless of who you're speaking to
a reply of ja indicates he really is
true
and a reply of da indicates that he's
either false or random
let's say it turns out that a really is
true
then we can ask effectively the same
question of b
and his answer will definitively
identify him as well
thereby solving the puzzle in just two
questions if instead we know only
that a is either false or random we just
use our second
question to ask if i ask you if you are
false would you say john
this will definitely identify a and then
we can use our third question to repeat
the process with b
as always it's not so important that you
chase through every possibility
rather it's the progression of ideas
that's important
bulos use difficult nested biconditional
questions
roberts noticed that normal conditionals
are sufficient and this simplified the
solution considerably
but then rayburn and rayburn devise a
fundamentally different approach
which made it possible simply to get
useful answers to our questions
regardless of who we're speaking to
this is what it's like to work in an
academic setting
each researcher brings his own ideas to
a problem
gradually improving and building upon
the work of others
so have we reached the end of our story
not even close
there's much much more for example you
might be wondering what the big deal is
about using three questions why can't we
do it in two
well rayburn and rayburn found a way of
doing just that
though their method was based on taking
advantage of an ambiguity in the way
bulows
initially stated the problem and then we
can wonder about making the hardest
logic puzzle ever even harder
what if random were really random in
other words
what if he really did just answer your
question as though he hadn't heard what
you said
instead of always behaving either as
true or as false
these are interesting questions and much
has been written about them
this is a long and winding saga and
we've seen only a small portion of it
here
but for now we'll call it a day see you
next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]